hey everyone today we're gonna build
Angry Birds I'm sure you're all familiar
with that game it's the super popular
hit game by Rovio entertainment the
first one launched way back in 2009 and
was itself a clone of another popular
game and crushed the castle anyway this
whole thing spawned an entire empire of
Angry Birds stuff like cartoons video
game tie-ins and at least two movies so
far now for our Angry Birds
implementation we'll need some sort of
2d physics library and as you can see on
Google there's no shortage of those it's
not incredibly important which one you
choose for this kind of basic physics
I'm just guessing that they're mostly
interchangeable I'll go with matter GS
and it's at the top here from a quick
tour of their website the library looks
pretty complete and they've got quite
extensive set of demo showing off the
engines capabilities this should be more
than enough to handle the simple physics
we need to build Angry Birds most
importantly and extremely fortunate for
us they have an existing demo with
mechanics extremely close to what we
need in our Angry Birds implementation
and you can see the full sources here
which will provide us a great
jumping-off point for our project the
first thing I'm going to do is include a
link to the library in our index.html
file and then copy and paste that
slingshot demo source code wholesale
into our bare-bones application now
we've got it running here in the browser
and so I can fling balls at these
pyramids and this is gonna work out
great half the work is already done for
us the next step is to start making this
look a bit more like Angry Birds
so let's ditch the blocks of pyramids
instead we'll have a ball balancing a
little stand eventually we'll make these
balls into the pigs
now that's working I'll use that little
helper function I made create stand to
stamp out a few more we'll do three and
then a taller one and you can see that
all I'm doing is recreating an actual
level from one of the Angry Birds games
there's one thing missing here that I'll
add which is the slope ground they're
all standing on and for that we'll need
to dig into the matter das talks a bit
on how to define a custom shape and
we'll end up using this matter dot body
dot from vertices function see I've
defied the vertices for the slope ground
and when we reload the browser the scene
generally looks similar to the Angry
Birds one I've got the slope ground at
the front and then a bigger one just off
screen to the right and you'll see that
objects roll back if they get knocked
off to that side the next step is I've
got a bang out some hard assets so you
can watch me draw some pigs and birds
here
now that we have some art assets let's
get them into the game we'll scale back
the scene and just start with getting
the sky in the ground to appear what
I've done here is created a mini entity
component system with the sprite
behavior and a rigidbody behavior and
this frights position just gets updated
from the rigid bodies the whole point of
this is to keep them in sync when we
load that up in the browser there we go
sky and ground showing up now we need to
add those stands back in and we'll skip
the pig on the top at first we'll modify
the create stand function to create two
entities one for the leg and one for the
platform now note that in the browser
and our stands are back to create the
pig we pass in a new parameter which is
the type of rigid body and that's a
polygon type and here inside their rigid
body behavior we check that and create a
polygon instead of a rectangular rigid
body that's all it takes if you load
that up the pigs appear I noticed at
this point that when you drag the
objects around nothing turns and falls
down as you'd expect which means that
we're not handling the orientation of
the originals correctly in matter da GS
each object has an angle associated with
it and so we need to read that property
and then apply it to the sprite
converting from radians to degrees since
phaser expects degrees load that into
the browser and if I go screw around
with the scene a bit and moving the
blocks around and making a mess
everything falls as expected the
orientation of the sprite is synced
properly with the rigidbody now next up
is getting that sloped ground drawn
properly you can see that if I just
create the rigidbody as I did before
the sprite is super offset from the
expected spot even when I try to
normalize all the values around the
origin same issue the sprite is really
off I ended up looking at the docs for
this function and although they kind of
mentioned the origin being the center of
mass that's not super helpful what I
ended up having to do is dropping a
breakpoint on the rigidbody creation
inside the behavior and that lets me
look at the properties of the object
coming right out of Matt
is and so scrolling through the
properties here I can see that the
object defines a balance was min Max
values pretty sure that's going to give
me the center of mass the docs are
talking about so going back to the code
if I take those into account and
transform the sprite by the center of
mass we should end up in the right spot
loading this in the browser again
everything looks right now the slope
ground is in the right spot now the last
thing we need to do is code up some sort
of lost condition so for each of the
pigs I'm going to add this new lost
behavior what this does is checks the
pigs position and if it's fallen too far
from the initial starting position we'll
consider that pig to have been hit and
it'll notify this right behavior to
changes image now when we now go over a
few of the pigs they clearly look like
they've been hit and this is working
final thing I want to throw up some sort
of you've one text on the screen once
you knock over all the pigs each of
these lost behaviors the pigs have will
just increment a counter and once we've
accounted for all the pigs in the game
we can throw this you win text over the
screen if I try it out in the game and
go and knock over a few of the pigs with
the birds once all the pigs fall you can
get this big you win text on the screen
and at this point I think we can call
this done now of course this is super
unpolished you can keep going and add
more levels and scores effects
animations it's up to you the source
code is all available on github so fork
it and go ahead and tweak it do it
everyone with it if you want to see more
videos like this in the future make sure
to hit like and subscribe and I'll see
you next time Cheers
you